[موسيقى]
هذه صحائف انزلت بفترات
متفاوته تاريخيه واخرها نزلت على نبينا
مبارك اخر انبيائنا يحيى بن زكريا عليه
وعلى كل الانبياء السلام ورد في القران
الكريم
ياخذ الكتاب بقوه واتيناها الحكمه صبيه
الركن الثاني من اركان الديانه والصباغه
صبغه هو الارتماس او التعميد في الماء
الجاري الغطس قطع النفس ثم الخروج هو حياه
جديده
همم
حياه جديده لكي يرتبط الاسم همم اسم الفرد
بهذا العالم المادي بعوامل النور العلياء
الركن الاخر من اركان ديانتنا هو الصدقه
ووجوب اعطائها يجب ان تعطى الى الفقير
والمحتاج الى الارمله والى تحرير الاسير
والى الكلمات الطيبه يعني الصدقه ليست
ماديه
[موسيقى]
يتالفوا كتاب مندائيين من قسمين القسم
الاول ويتضمن سفر التكوين وتعاليم الوحي
العظيم والصراع الدائره بين الخير والشر
والنور والظلام وكذلك هبوط النفس في جسد
ادم ويتضمن كذلك تسبيحا للخالق واحكاما
فقهيه ودينيه اما القسم الثاني فيتناول
قضايا النفس وما يلحقها من عقاب والثواب
وللمندائيه قواسم وطقوس مشتركه مع بقيه
الديانات الابراهيميه الاخرى مثل الصوم
والصلاه وعباده اخرى
ايه عندنا الصوم الصوم الكبير والصوم
الصغير الصوم الكبير هو عدم الاتيان بباطل
في هذه الحياه يعني التجنب المحرمات في
ديانه من المدعيه هنالك محرمات كثيره
وتشترك فيها اغلب الاديان وهي الكبائر
ثلاث الزنا
الشرك بالله والقدر المكان الذي خلفي هذا
يسمى شحنته هذا هو بناء يبنى بطريقه دينيه
خاصه في اسرار السبعه السبعه هي همم خلق
العوالم من قبل الحياه العظيم في كل
الاديان انه العالم خلقا في سبعه ايام سته
ايام واستراحه في اليوم السابع
فيبنى من اليمين سبع من الاعلى سبع من
القصب
من القصب والطين وجذع النحل جذع النخل
يعتبر سر الاب نحن لدينا روحانيات كبيره
في هذا سر الاب وسر الاوفياء في هذه
الحياه مثلا الارض يعتبر رحم ام السماء
تعتبر الاب الذهب والفضه الذهب يعتبر سر
الاب الفضل سر الام القصب والبردي القصب
الذي يلف به الميت يعتبر سر الاب والبردي
هو سر الام الذي يعتبر مثل الرحم
فهذا تجرى فيه الطقوس الدينيه الكبرى